c'est vrai que c'est pas bien
Stéphane Guillon
Stéphane Guillon mesdames messieurs
salut Stéphane
[Applaudissements]
Guillon cravate pour Guy Bedos toujours
j'en ai jamais
alors
la semaine dernière Neuilly-sur-Seine
s'embraser complot injures bousculade et
finalement c'est Villiers-le-Bel qui a
trinqué
[Applaudissements]
controverse sur la médiatisation des
arrestations ah regardez cette photo
pleine de retenue publiée dans match un
jeune noir menotté en slip pour une fois
qu'on montre une minorité visible
si ça se trouve depuis il a été
innocenté grâce à match aujourd'hui
c'est une vedette
[Applaudissements]
un ex élu de Neuilly jugé pour viol sur
mineur décidément Neuilly c'est vraiment
une banlieue qui craint
toujours à Neuilly Sophie Favier se
lance en politique un traître un violeur
et une idiote ça fait beaucoup pour une
seule ville
une nouvelle qui devrait faire plaisir à
Brice Hortefeu les insectes immigrés en
Europe sont fichés oui on veut bien se
faire piquer mais par des moustiques
français
société après l'autorisation d'inscrire
un enfant mort-né à l'état civil
l'église réclame un statut pour
l'embryon prochaine étape les
spermatozoïdes qu'on puisse enterrer
dignement nos préservatifs
minimum quand même
[Applaudissements]
Renaud gagne le droit de construire la
future voiture présidentielle une Vel
Satis rallongée de plusieurs centimètres
une voiture pour Sarko faléose
une cliente reçoit une facture de
téléphone de 63 millions d'euros si ça
vous arrive ne la payez pas
pour la première fois Bill Clinton s'est
exprimé publiquement sur les gadrilles
que lui prodiguait Monica Lewinsky
bien non merci
[Applaudissements]
sport Salim Sdiri qui a reçu un javelot
dans le dos en juillet dernier a réussi
un saut en longueur de 7 mètres 81 une
nouvelle technique d'entraînement
quelqu'un lui a dit fais gaffe s'aligne
un Javeau qui arrive
Mimie Mathy fête ses 10 ans de Joséphine
10 ans bientôt l'adolescence
faudrait songer à grandir maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est pas bien
je la connais la petite Mimi c'est la
prairie la petite Mimi
[Applaudissements]
selon gala Nicolas Sarkozy aurait
demandé à Michel Drucker de préparer un
spécial Vivement dimanche pour la sortie
de l'album de Carla Bruni eh Drucker il
va l'envoyer péter c'est sûr comme il
l'a dit dans match on n'a jamais été
complaisant avec les politiques
le restaurant La Cantine du faubourg
expose des photos de pieds de vedette
Manu Chao Sandrine kiberling Catherine
Briat et le clou de l'expo Carla et
Nicolas
et on termine avec un coup de chapeau à
Stéphane Bern qui en plus d'assister à
l'enterrement de Salvador c'est
collectidés Mireille Mathieu c'est pas
assez courageux
alors Stéphane vous avez vu que votre
votre ami bebedo c'est avec nous ce soir
vous avez lu son bouquin je n'ai je l'ai
lu
j'ai adoré voilà je voulais juste vous
dire
qu'après la sortie de ce petit Bruno
Sarko & Co je m'en vais vu en plus ce
que je balance sur son sbire brille sur
feu je préfère partir de moi-même
question d'élégance demain je reprends
un bateau pour Alger avec tous mes potes
pieds-noirs
Marthe Villalonga elle ça va les
rigolote c'est ma copine mais l'idée
d'être avec Roger Hanin m'emmerde
sur la même rafios ça m'excite
au poker Bacri qui fait la gueule comme
d'habitude et Afflelou faisant avec une
serveuse qui a l'âge de sa fille
la deuxième monture est offerte voilà
c'est fini le vieux clown c'est clipse
comédienne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu